welcome back and let's write some more
neat code today so today let's solve the
problem longest increasing path in a
matrix and while this is a hard problem
i would definitely say it's one of the
more doable hard problems there's
nothing crazy involved but it is
somewhat difficult we're given an m by n
matrix
that is filled with integers and the
integers are going to be i believe zero
or greater than zero so mostly positive
integers and we want to return the
length of the longest increasing path in
this matrix and we are allowed to move
only in four directions left right up or
down we're not allowed to move
diagonally and of course we can't go
outside of the boundaries so let's just
start with some observations first of
all this is an example and you can see
that this is the path that is the
longest it's of length four and it's in
increasing order obviously we can start
with pretty much any value right and
pretty much starting at any position we
can create a path of at least length one
right this is a path of length one this
is a path of length one uh but you know
starting from here then the next
position that we go to is a two it has
to be greater than one which it is and
then the next one is six that's greater
and then nine that's also greater but
from here uh we can't really go anywhere
else right we're allowed to move here uh
but this one is not greater than nine
it's just exactly nine so that's the
longest path now one thing you might be
wondering is can we you know reuse the
same value multiple times right what if
we have a loop of some kind well just
think about it for a second if this is
an increasing path of course we can't
reuse any values because take a look at
our path right you know the value that
we get to is going to be greater than
all the previous values anyway so how
could we possibly reuse any of the
values in our path we're not allowed to
now they don't state that in the problem
statement but that's an observation that
you have to make on your own and in this
case you know that's true and another
observation we can make without even
trying to understand you know what's the
algorithm we'd use for this problem just
by looking at this example we can make a
very important observation and that is
that if this is the longest increasing
path and it's of length four that means
the longest increasing path starting at
this position is going to be of length
four but what about the longest
increasing path starting at this
position over here what is it going to
be in this case we can see that there is
a path right now starting from it that's
increasing that's of length three is
there going to be any paths starting
from this position that are gonna be
larger than three of course not because
if there were wouldn't this entire path
be longer than four if we found a path
an increasing path starting from this
position that was not three but it was
actually four then you know let's say it
looks something like this right uh then
of course the longest increasing path
from here would be five now what i'm
saying might not make sense to you just
yet but now let's actually understand
how we can approach the solution to this
problem and then i bet it will make
sense now let's think about this what's
the most basic brute force way that we
could find the longest increasing path
well we could basically start at every
single position and say maybe the
longest increasing path will start here
maybe it'll start here maybe it'll start
here right who knows
they don't tell us where we have to
start so we pretty much have to try
every single position that's the brute
force and let's say we you know record
that in a grid that's the same size as
the grid we have here i'm going to call
it lip for longest increasing path and
once we do that once we've filled up
every value in here we can just take the
maximum of them and then return that
that'll be the length of the longest
increasing path okay so for any
particular position how do we find the
longest length well the brute force
again is just going to be a simple dfs i
hope you're familiar with the dfs
algorithm it's a pretty standard graph
algorithm and you definitely will need
it for hard level problems we're going
to run a dfs starting from this position
going in four directions right up down
left right of course if we go out of
bounds to the top or to the left or any
other direction we're not going to
continue there of course okay so we
can't go out of bounds let's try going
right starting from here are we allowed
to go here well we have to compare the
values right we have to look at this
value is it greater than the previous
value it's not greater than the previous
value so we can't go here right we're
not allowed to go there starting from
here okay let's try going down that's
the only position left that we have it's
a six that's also not greater than nine
so we can't go there either uh so we're
pretty much uh not allowed to go
anywhere so what's the length uh from
here it's one because remember
one is basically like the default value
we can always have a length of one
starting at any position okay so we did
that now let's go to the next position
similarly we're not allowed to go in any
of the four directions because none of
them have a greater value so we'll also
put a one here okay now let's try the
four and this is where things are going
to get interesting so pay attention we
can't go up we can't go to the right but
we can go to the left
and finally we see a value that's
greater than the original 9 is greater
than 4 so we are allowed to go here
that's awesome
but now
we're doing dfs does that mean
recursively we're going to run dfs on
this position again well we don't have
to because we already ran dfs on this
position and we already found the
longest increasing path starting from
that position the length of it is one so
we don't have to repeat that work
because we stored the repeated work
inside of this matrix so we know that
starting from four we can go to this
nine and that's a path of length two
that's at least one path that we can
create okay we do have one more
direction to try though we can from four
we can go
down to the a we haven't ran dfs on this
position yet so we're gonna have to do
that now dfs okay let's go to the right
that's out of bounds okay let's go up
should we even go up well in reality we
shouldn't but if our algorithm is
programmed to try going up it'll still
work for us because of course we came
from the 4 so we know that the value up
above is less than eight so if we try
going up it's not going to work anyway
so it's okay to leave that in the code
because it's not going to break anything
so that's good for us because it keeps
our dfs pretty simple okay now let's try
going down we can't go down because one
is less than eight we want it to be
greater than eight let's try going to
the left okay six is also less than
eight we want it to be greater than
eight okay so we couldn't go anywhere
but we'd still uh
of the two paths both of them were the
same length so we can put a two here uh
starting from this position the longest
increasing path is length two but did we
do anything else well we started at the
eight we ran dfs from this position so
not only did we determine that the the
lip from here is two but we also
determined that the lip from eight is
one because we couldn't go anywhere
starting from eight are you starting to
see how this algorithm itself even the
dfs brute force is not inefficient
because we're caching the work we're
storing the work in a matrix so this
isn't even a brute force solution as
long as you implement it correctly it's
actually very efficient as long as we
don't repeat the work so now when we
we're not we're not quite at the eight
yet right because we're going in order
in our uh matrix but once we get to the
eight we'll know we already ran dfs on
it and we won't have to repeat that work
so now that you're probably starting to
get the idea i'm going to start fast
forwarding through this explanation so
now let's run dfs starting from the six
we try going left can't we try going
right we can't we try going down we also
can't do that we try going up okay we
can do that and we know that we already
computed the lip from here it's one so
we can say the lips from starting at six
is going to be two now let's go to the
second six we can't go left it's less
than six we can't go down it's also less
than six we can go to the right uh we
already computed the lip from here so we
know that this will be a path of length
two we know that because uh we're just
going to take the value here that we
computed and just add it to uh you know
one from here so
that's uh one possibility we could also
go up we already computed the lip from
up it's also one so basically we have a
tie right and that tie is going to be of
length two so we can put a two in this
position and then when we get to the 8
we're going to try running dfs on it but
before we do we're going to see we've
already computed it so we don't repeat
that work uh starting from 2 we only
have two possibilities can't go to the
right but we can go up above and up
above we're not going to rerun dfs on
this position because we already
computed it over here it's length two so
we can say the lip starting from this
position is one plus the two value
that's above it so it's going to be
three and same here we can try going up
uh which will be one plus two because
the value up above it is two we can try
going to the right that's not gonna work
we can we can't go down but we can go to
the left and that's gonna be one plus
three of course one plus three is
greater than one plus two so uh the
value we're going to put here uh in our
lip is gonna be four and uh fast
forwarding this i think this is gonna
look up above and then that's just gonna
be one plus one so we're gonna put a two
here and then we're going to take the
max from our lip which is of course 4
and we're going to return 4. we don't
actually have to return the path itself
just the length of it in this case which
is 4. okay so that's the solution and
it's pretty efficient but how do we know
it's efficient what's the time
complexity of course the memory
complexity is big o n times m those are
the dimensions of the matrix because
we're using extra space here but what's
the time complexity it's also big o of n
times m now how do i know that i don't
know how quickly i can give you like a
formal proof of it but let's just think
about the intuition behind it let's say
our matrix was in such a way that when
we ran dfs at the first position we you
know had a path such like this and then
we went here and then we went there then
here then here then here basically we
visit the entire matrix in one dfs
that's going to take big o of n times m
to run that dfs but the good thing about
that is going to be after we've done
that we're going to have computed every
lip from every single position right and
then when we visit the remainder
remaining values of the matrix each of
those is going to be computed in big o
of one time so you know having done the
repeated work at the beginning wasn't
such a big deal because the remainder is
going to be very easy or in the worst
case maybe starting from each position
let's say they're all the same exact
value right let's say each of them was
exactly nine in that case we wouldn't
really run dfs on any of them well we
would try to but we'd see that we can't
go in any of the four directions so for
each of these in that case as well the
time complexity would be big o of one
which means the overall time complexity
would be n times m once again so i hope
you're kind of getting the intuition
behind why this is an efficient solution
um and with that being said let's
finally jump into the code okay so now
let's code it up and i'm sure you know
that i like to write these kind of
two-dimensional graph problems uh matrix
problems in a very formulaic way and
i've done it so many times that actually
don't even have to think about it i
always do this i always take the
dimensions of the matrix put it in some
static variables rows and columns
because we know we're going to run dfs
on this so we're going to need to know
those dimensions in this case we're
gonna have a two-dimensional matrix or
cache i'm gonna call it dp and i'm
actually gonna set it to be a hash map
because it's pretty easy to do that in
python uh we can use two values to
access this right and those the key
value is basically going to be row
column which is going to map to the lip
the longest increasing path now of
course you could just use a
two-dimensional matrix if you're doing
this in java or whatever if you want and
maybe i honestly should do that as well
but i'm really used to doing it this way
because you can kind of just turn your
brain off
and next we're going to use
dfs we have a function inside of a
function so we don't have to pass in
every variable such as these three that
i defined up above but we are going to
pass in the position that we're
currently visiting which is the row
column coordinate and we want to make
sure that the pass the path is an
increasing order so we are going to pass
in what the previous value ends up being
and then with all uh you know graph
traversals the first thing you want to
check is did we go out of bounds is the
row less than zero or is the row exactly
equal to the number of rows which means
it's too big um or
same exact thing with the column is
column less than zero or is column equal
to the number of columns because that
means it's too big and the last
condition in this case is going to be is
the path not increasing how do we know
that well the value that we're currently
visiting which is the matrix at the row
column position is
less than or equal to the previous value
that means it's not increasing and if
it's not increasing then we are just
going to return we can return zero just
to say that the increasing path was just
zero okay so that's one base case and
the second base case is a little bit
easier that's if we already computed the
lip at this position rc and if this and
we know that because if this is in our
dp hash map as a key value then we can
return whatever the length of it was
that we computed and ended up storing in
our dp cache so there we go okay now to
actually compute the length we're just
going to call it result and initially
set it to 1 because we know it's at
least going to be one that's the minimum
it could possibly be and now we could
use a loop to go through all four of the
directions but i don't think it's really
necessary we can just kind of copy and
paste the same line like four times i
prefer doing that rather than doing a
loop but you can do what you prefer so
one we know we're going to
run dfs right we're going to run dfs on
one of the neighboring positions one of
them could be r plus one
and then the column is the same and what
is going to be the previous value that
we passed and of course it's going to be
the current value right now so row
column and we only want to update the
result if this is greater than the
result so what we want to do is set this
equal or actually this alone is not
going to be the length because this is
going to tell us the longest increasing
path starting at row plus one and if
that's the case what we actually want
the length to be is from this position
that we're currently at so we're going
to take this
and add 1 to it 1 plus that similar to
how i was doing it or i was talking
about it in the drawing explanation okay
so once we have that then we want to
take the max of the current
maximum result maximum length and the
max of this and then you know update it
accordingly and this is where we copy
and paste uh four times because we want
to go in all four of the directions so r
plus one r minus one
also column plus one and column minus
one okay and when we're done with that
the last thing we have to do is now that
we've actually computed the lip starting
at this position we want to make sure to
actually throw it into our dp cache so
let's do that before we end up returning
so let's store that and then once we've
stored it we can go ahead and return it
so then the next time if we ever call
dfs starting from the same position
we'll end up returning it from our cache
rather than redoing the dfs so that's
where we're saving our time now that
we've defined our dfs all that's left is
to actually call it and remember we want
to run dfs starting from pretty much
every single position in the grid so we
can do a nested for loop to do that so
go through every row go through every
single column when we do that we also
want to run dfs on every
coordinate and what's the previous value
that we're going to pass in for that
well we know that every value in the
matrix is going to be
zero or greater than zero so a default
value we can pass in for the previous
value uh is negative one because we
never want this to return if we're
looking at like the first value right
and so if we pass in negative one this
uh comparison will never evaluate to
true right none of these values is ever
going to be less than negative one
that's good so that's why we're doing it
like this
so
once we've done that
we're good to go the last thing we have
to do is just return whatever the
maximum was so we can just take our dp
values which will return a list of all
the values and just take the maximum of
that now we probably don't need to do it
like this like we could have just
maintained another variable over here
maybe i've just called it lip longest
increasing path and then just
continuously updated it based on the
maximum that was returned you can do it
however you want the time complexity is
the same even though we're iterating
over the entire you know matrix again
pretty much by doing this that's the
idea let's just run this to make sure
that it works and as you can see on the
left yes it does work and it's about as
efficient as you can get for this
problem so i really hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it really supports the channel
a lot consider checking out my patreon
where you can further support the
channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching